HAD A CHANCE TO SPEAK TO KEVIN
DURANT.
>> CONGRATULATIONS TO KEVIN
DURANT, BECAUSE IT HAS BEEN
ANNOUNCED THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
ADDED TO THE ANNIVERSARY TEAM,
AND WHAT DOES THAT MEAN TO YOU?
>> WELL, IT MEANS A LOT.
IT MEANS EVERYTHING, TO BE
HONEST, BECAUSE YOU WANT TO
LEAVE YOUR MARK IN THIS LEAGUE
ON THE GAME OF BASKETBALL,
ITSELF, AND TO BE AMONGST THE
GREATEST THAT THE LEAGUE HAS
EVER SEEN AND TO BE IN THAT
COMPANY IS SWEET.
AS A KID, I HAVE SEEN THE 50th
ANNIVERSARY, AND I ALWAYS
DREAMED TO HAVE ONE OF THE
JACKETS ON, AND TO BE IN THAT
GROUP AND THE BROTHERHOOD, AND
IT FEELS GOOD TO BE IN THAT
GROUP.
>> WELL, YOU ARE CERTAINLY IN
IT, AND CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT MAKING YOUR
MARK, AND YOU HAVE ONE
CHAMPIONSHIP AND HERE IN
BROOKLYN AND GAME ONE OF THE
SEASON, AND WHAT MAKES YOU THINK
THAT THIS TEAM HAS WHAT IT
TAKES?
WHAT MAKE YOU SPECIAL?
>> WELL, WE HAVE A LOT OF TALENT
ON THE TEAM, AND A GREAT
COACHING STAFF AND A GOOD
SUPPORT SYSTEM.
THAT IS A GOOD START THERE.
BUT FOR US, WE HAVE A VETERAN
GROUP OF GUYS WHO HAVE BEEN
THROUGH A LOT, AND HOPEFULLY WE
WILL BUILD ON THAT AND MAKE IT A
GOOD SEASON.
WE DON'T WANT TO BE, YOU KNOW,
WE DON'T WANT TO ROUND OUT THE
SHAPE IN THE FIRST GAME, AND WE
KNOW HOW TOUGH THAT IS, BUT WE
WANT TO START THIS THING OUT
RIGHT.
>> SO THAT IS GOING FOR THE
THIRD CHAMPIONSHIP IF YOU MAKE
IT HAPPEN THIS SEASON.
YOU KNOW WHAT A TOUGH ROAD THAT
IS, AND YOU JUST TALKED ABOUT
THE LONG-TERM GOAL, AND THINGS
ARE HAPPENING DIFFERENTLY FOR
YOU ALL THAN THINGS EXPECTED.
WITHOUT KYRIE IN THE PICTURE,
WHAT DOES IT CHANGE FOR YOU IN
THE OFFENSIVE END?
>> YEAH, GUYS WILL HAVE TO STEP
UP AND FILL THAT VOID.
HE MEANT A LOT TO OUR TEAM, AND
SO I THINK THAT WE HAVE GUYS
READY FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY, AND
ALWAYS THE NEXT-MAN-UP MENTALITY
IN PRO SPORTS, AND SO WE TRUST
EVERYBODY IN THE LOCKER ROOM